das ist der absolute hammer ibm verkauft
den ersten quantencomputer auf dem
freien markt noch steht der preis nicht
fest aber fest steht der quantencomputer
mit 20 cubes kommt auf dem markt der ibm
system one
ich bekomme gänsehaut ein neues
zeitalter bricht an
jetzt zwei klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst er kein video herzlich
willkommen
wir hatten schon darüber berichtet
bisher konnte man sich schon über das
web auf einem ibm quantencomputer
einloggen und rechenzeiten auf ihn
mieten die quantentechnologie arbeitet
dabei im hintergrund wer mit einem
quantencomputer arbeiten will muss
lediglich mit den apps also den
application programming interfaces den
programmierschnittstellen die von ibm
bereitgestellt werden programmieren von
kranken computern muss man im prinzip
nichts verstehen es ist der erste
supercomputer einer neuen generation
durch die quantentechnologie können
aufgaben viel schneller berechnet werden
und der datentransfer funktioniert über
verschränkte teilchen die sogenannten
cupid es ist wirklich bemerkenswert
wofür moderne computer eine ewigkeit
brauchen können kranken computer viel
viel viel schneller rechnen weil sie
alles gleichzeitig machen können denn
die quanten befinden sich in einer super
position nicht wie bei biz im zustand 0
oder 1 sondern in beiden und noch viel
mehr
deshalb rechnen sie nicht 1+2 gleich
drei sondern xy gleich z mit allen
möglichen ergebnissen ibm rechnet mit
fortschritten bei vielen komplexen
problemen medikamentenforschung
berechnungen in der logistik
finanzwirtschaft künstliche intelligenz
datensicherheit zitat das ibm system one
ist ein wichtiger schritt in richtung
kommerzialisierung des quantencomputers
dieses neue system ist entscheidend für
die erweiterung befanden computer über
die grenzen des forschungslabors hinaus
wären wir an der entwicklung praktischer
brannten anwendung für wirtschaft und
wissenschaft arbeiten so albern christa
senior vice president von hybrid cloud
und direktor von ibm research wir stehen
wirklich vor einem neuen zeitalter der
informationstechnologie und dieses jahr
kann man sie schon kaufen wie viel die
2,2 mal 2,7 meter rechner kosten werden
ist allerdings noch nicht bekannt
allerdings heißt es jetzt bei ibm von
apple lernen heißt siegen lernen nur
dass sie es noch ein wenig weiter
treiben den ibm ko-system man kann man
nicht bei amazon oder sonst wo sie
einfach bestellen man muss eine
partnerschaft mit ibm eingehen womit man
dann noch zugang zur quanten software
und zu weiteren cloud basierten
quantencomputern bekommt es ist wirklich
absolut irre wie auch dass menschen
können tatsächlich übermenschliche
kräfte entwickeln wie das erklärt
neugier zone in diesem video unbedingt
drauf klicken und unbedingt abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran